I received the mosaic test, but the protocol says to use first year in the morning.
That is at least six hours old. I cannot hold my urine for that long. Even overnight,
due to the cancer in my abdomen, should I wait to do this test at states of the urine?
Can't be too diluted for the test to work. No, don't wait. Still just run that. Let's say,
okay, so I think this person is talking about they're having to get up and go to the bathroom every
hour or two because of a mass that's in their abdominal cavity. So they have pressure on the bladder
and they can't hold it more than a couple hours. So there's no way I'm getting six hours,
and I can't hold it. Just run the test. If it comes back where the creatine level is off,
then they won't then you'll get an abdominal bite. So they do a pre-test to see if the test is valid.
If they reject it, then we're back to round zero, and we have to roll request new kits.
But just just go ahead and run the test.